it's been one of the funniest TV shows
on on the small screen ever since it
came into being its veep on HBO that
just wrapped up its seventh and final
season last night and joining us here is
the man whose character just like his
Twitter feed is not for the faint of
heart
good to see Timothy Simon's here who
plays Jonah Ryan on that show good to
see you brother it's good to see you man
so what's going through your mind right
now
well I wrapped up I've still have not
fully processed it like yeah I just were
I'm still here talking about it I think
I'm gonna really realize it like a few
weeks from now when like you know we're
kind of in knowing we're still dealing
with the reactions to it like sort of
the overnight reactions like you know
texts from family members and stuff like
that we're still sort of still living
fully inside of it so I think it'll be a
couple weeks from now that I'll hit a
wall I'll hit a wall well I saw on your
Twitter feed a video or photo where you
all together watching this show yeah
yeah we we got together it's been
something that we've always done in the
past we've always gotten together to
watch the last episode of the season
usually we will go over to Julia's house
but just because it was the finale we
ended up we kind of we got as many
people as we could there anybody that
was in town went over to the the CAA
screening room mm-hmm
and we had some dinner over there and we
just all watched it together and for a
lot of us it was the first time that we
had seen it so it was like it was damn
near almost an hour long now let me ask
you this question because what is your
take on spoilers here because I know
some people have not seen it including
them some who are in this room right oh
no well I mean I feel like I mean we've
had to keep him under wraps for so long
right that I feel like it aired we got
to be able to talk about it like I'm
really sorry to the people that haven't
but like it's just you should have
watched it last night man right yeah
where your character almost reached the
highest office almost he was almost
there
which is a hell of a run for Jonah Ryan
yeah and obviously this has come up sort
of in in interviews as like looking at
this season and compare it in comparison
to where he started and there is this
thing like if you had told me at the
beginning of this show that Jonah Ryan
like the liaison
from that from the would like to the
vice president's office from the White
House would ultimately be in Congress
I'd be like okay yeah like a lot of
idiots get elected to Congress like that
happens all the time but very few idiots
have almost become president well I came
in say that's true but like I would have
been like alright that's a stretch that
this specific character is gonna end up
almost becoming president or or even
really have a shot right but this whole
this whole season for me is like we now
live in a world where this narcissistic
unskilled untalented racist like this
shrieking ball of hot rage it isn't
you're gonna have a hard time convincing
me he's not the guy that's definitely
gonna win that he's not the one that is
like the the one with the best chance of
one well there's many times where things
in real life Congress or anything
including both sides of the aisle have
been set to the veep music and closing
credits yes it has been remarkable how
so many times the show has actually
foreshadowed real-life politics it
started with our pilot with a guy who
made like an errand to like we had like
you know it's just Selena makes an
arrant tweet about the cornstarch
utensils about you know biodegradable
corn starch she tends the cornstarch
utensils and that upsets the oil
industry that's their first episode and
that happened that happened some guy
made it like may upset the oil industry
right before our first season aired and
even in the last week we saw we saw it
happened twice like the kid that sued
his school because he didn't want to get
the chickenpox vaccine and then he got
chickenpox there was that kid but then
12 hours later you have well I got a
trump rally you have somebody shouting
shoot him right or shoot them about
immigrants moments after somebody in a
Jonah rally has yelled killem about
whenever Emmitt when immigrants are
mentioned in one of his speeches like
it's just they're coming through hourly
right frankly it's great we stopped this
show
you know about all that is it is really
funny and the whole cast has been
brilliant you in particular to 2 Timothy
Symons here on the Rich Eisen show we
had a great day at the under golf course
we did about Mochis about two months ago
yeah yeah yeah we're it's a rainy day
and we get to go out on a beautiful golf
course here in Los Angeles and play with
Adam Scott yes one of that ACTRA this is
coming not actor Adam Scott actual like
the most
Adam Scott actor beautiful man he's a
great man to you Adam Scott the golfer
the most beautiful man that's ever
walked the earth and unbelievably
talented it couldn't be nicer and right
now we've got up on the screen right
here and I honestly don't know why they
chose this one I took this photograph of
this the leaderboard that was I think
right next to one of the the tea boxes
yeah where you had a better Club speed
but I had a better ball speed and and I
drove you by about 17 yards according to
this you did oh oh so you have no idea
why they chose this one that's so
strange but there's a photograph of us
just chilling out it was an inclement
day but it was a total blast man it was
that was so much fun
Adam Scott at some point like he liked
both he and his caddy like because I
I've collapsed like a house of cards I
mean I can barely play golf as it is and
then you sure and then they say why
don't you go play golf in front of
somebody who's won the Masters it
becomes an impossibility and I think
they were just sick of watching me shank
balls they were like Adam Scott was like
a come here come here come here and he
like gave me a couple's what he took
what what swing yeah I was too close I
was set up too close to the ball you
gotta get further away yeah and like
instead of instead of like instead of
thinking throwing your weight forward
thinking of throwing your weight down
and honestly I went out three days later
Matt Walsh has a charity tournament this
year yeah I shot the best score I've
ever shot my life three days later only
thinking about those two but in real
time on that day itself you could not
put it into practice put it into
practice like on to shot and put it
together I put it together a couple
shots and but man that was that was the
most fun I've ever had playing golf it
was amazing and
and you were there so you can you can
you can give the the checkmark of
authenticity to this story where I
believe it was like the par-4 13th I'm
standing over the ball I get two pops
two pieces of candy and he had a birdie
putt and I had a birdie putt and I
jarred mine for a birdie net Eagle
birdie net Eagle that is true and I just
looked at him up too you could pick that
ball up dude actually looks up like
there's gonna be a camera Automator
there are there are three people there
that art that aren't contractually
obligated to be there and one of them
was a friend of mine gives it a little
just this thing he might as well as done
like that have done it but Dustin
Johnson like slow play fist pump
it was brilliant it was brilliant
there's the only thing just to go not
not take the cap off a little tug oh my
god you could pick that up which by the
way he's not allowed to do he actually
it was like a good 15 18 no it was it
was a legitimately beautiful thank you
sir
I was like I'm not come on I'm not gonna
come in here ally like if it wasn't a
good putt I would have said it was I
know what it really was a great putt and
I want to thank you here in front of our
audience as well for you to do that
Funny or Die video for this show as they
get in the hole guy oh man
that was a total blast because we were
sitting here thinking all right let's
who is the get in the hole guy and how
can we do some sort of mock documentary
for it and then when they came back and
said that you would be available and
consider doing it we're right Chris like
we're not just saying it's right here
and you all know the trainer
authenticated my story that's in you are
the get in the hole gear the guy who
screams getting all it's always been
something that's fascinated me I'm and
this is coming from somebody who loves
yelling when you shouldn't yell that's
that's I've built an entire life in an
entire career out of it but it is like
it's a fascinating thing when somebody's
like why are you that why are you
yelling mashed potatoes this right now
let's just don't do that don't do that
amongst other people let alone at a golf
tournament that's like the one place
where you just are supposed to be like
just be polite that's the one place yeah
I know I was fantastic it was really fun
but you were you're great in that and
great in this as well let's uh let's
play celebrity true or false with the
Timothy Simon's here on the Rich Eisen
[Music]
all right the sting of Spandau Ballet
brings us in these are some things that
we saw on the internet or you have
mentioned in previous interviews that we
want confirmation on okay first thing I
was in this movie and pardon me for not
knowing this off the top my head you
were in drafting I was yeah that is true
yeah what was your role in drafting I
was one of the I was one of the scouts
in the war room and so I think like they
had they had three of us and it wasn't
necessarily mentioned in the script but
I I think we'd we had like this sort of
one like old-school like kind of gruff
Scout and then there was sort of like a
younger guy that like seemed like he was
very like he was sort of a well-built
guy and kind of got the sense that maybe
he was a former player scout maybe he
didn't make it in the NFL but yeah I I
think I was put there to be I was the
numbers guy you were then I think it was
never like this is kind of the back
story that I built up it hit being like
well how did I end up here and it was
like it's certainly because it's not
because I had like a really good career
as a tight end at Ohio State right so I
was the analytics guy I don't know I
don't know if you remember this or if
you were there but they had they showed
the raw footage of Goodell announcing
yes the the first pick for the movie
right which they actually did at the NFL
to live NFL Draft right in Radio City
Music Hall right that's where I shot my
scene that's where you shot your scene
sir I don't know if you remember this
but they of course put in some other
sound underneath it when it was in the
movie but they showed us the raw footage
when we were supposed to be reacting
does a number one pick yeah and when
Goodell comes out to announce the fake
number one pick in the movie the crowd
still booed him it's you know it's it's
his issue to bear but yeah every single
time he walks off the stage people want
to take photographs with him it's
unbelievable they go actively will boo
him but individually just like let's do
it it's crazy but being there that day
too it's they made us Ivan Reitman was
there the director was there
and they made us wear the same stuff
from Thursday night the night before
because they shot us in our real
environment that's right Thursday night
and they made us wear the same thing on
Friday and the story I've told before
and I'll tell you here - I did a scene
with Frank Langella what you never
thought I would ever do or ever say into
a microphone without a hint of irony and
I was too busy you know doing the draft
for the NFL Network leading up to it and
the night before and he walked on the
set on that Friday and he says would you
like to run through our lines just like
that and I panicked
on the spot because I'd never looked at
the script I just figured I would ad-lib
it with Frank Langella holy crap how did
it go well yeah but he wore sunglasses
this time that was his that was his
thing that I asked him I'm like what
like what's with the sunglasses he'd use
that I just figured that's what NFL
owners would wear in the same way that
you figured you were the analytics guy
yeah we just had we have to build it in
something you know who else was in that
movie and was there with you at the
draft was Kevin Dunn yeah I know that's
right one last one on this what was it
lag and you've you you've been in some
great stuff and you've worked with some
amazing people obviously what was it
want like watching Costner do his thing
cosplay is the end of sports movie Kevin
Costner thing I there is this there is a
moment where I I feel like in the movie
I like I go I think it was Bo Callahan
was the character's name is like
tumbling down the draft board and he's
having a moment with Jennifer Garner and
I come in I'm like you're not gonna
believe what's happening and it's that
this guy is tumbling down and the
continuation of that scene is that we
the three of us walk into the war room
together and I were right before we were
about to right before we were about to
enter into the war room they're about to
call action I just feel this hand on my
shoulder and it's Costner just giving me
like a little pat on the shoulder and it
was like in character or out of
character I didn't care I was like I
felt so supported it was like Kevin
Costner the coach or Kevin Costner the
GM yeah reassuring you that this was
gonna go well it's the best I've ever
felt
most confident I've ever felt like I
stood up a little bit straighter
I probably proceeded to blow that scene
in five different ways but in that
moment right before we walked in that
room like Costner was he was great to
watch he really was he was great in the
room I really enjoyed and we liked we
were stuck in that war room for a long
time yeah a solid month yeah and he was
great
I was just great because obviously he's
been there done that with sports movies
yes and the Big Finish it was just great
watching it with his speech at the end
yeah man I know a couple more things
here with Timothy Simon's is it true or
false you were discovered for veep after
appearing in a 2010 Geico commercial as
Abe Lincoln is that if that is that is
yeah that is pretty much true okay I so
I had a friend my friend Peter this one
right here so my my friend Peter was
worked for in the casting office of
Alison Jones and I actually ended up
doing a Taco Bell commercial that never
aired as Abraham Lincoln like maybe a
month after this cuz they had all the
pieces already it never aired I had to
ride of penny farthing which is that
bike with like a giant front wheel
you're like can you ride a penny for
everything and I was like iron rider I
can ride a fixed-gear like I'll be fine
and then I I like a hole over teakettle
first time I ever tried to ride a penny
farthing in front of the entire crew
over the handlebars and lucky I was not
in the hospital and ended up I ended up
by the end of the day I got it I wrote a
penny farthing in a commercial and was
even able to do a bit but like in the
whole suit and everything anyway my
friend Peter worked for Allison Jones I
had known him for a couple years and
that commercial came out and he said oh
you know my friend Tim just did this
thing he's he's really funny and check
this out and she and off of that she was
like well let's call him in for
something and and I had gone I think it
was like day player stuff on the office
but that was sort of how I got
introduced to the casting office that
cast me maybe seven months later and is
it true that the your character of Jonah
Ryan was originally written for a short
bald and bearded man a short fat bearded
guy didn't necessarily I don't think
bald is part of it but like it was
supposed to be like a heavyset
bearded just like a guy who's 26 but
looked like he would die of a heart
attack momentarily and I was the
frightening as far as I remember I was
the first guy in on the first day and
was like well this is never this is
never going to happen I'm literally the
first person that is auditioning for any
part on this show not just the Jonah
character acting and and usually at that
just like you're forgotten by the time
they end up getting through those
casting days you just forgot well but I
mean I couldn't imagine it being anybody
other than you I mean like you dominated
this role like it looked like you just
took whatever was on the page or
whatever was between your temples that
wasn't on the page and you just chewed
it up and you spit it out you swallowed
it all over again I mean just awesome
thank you I mean the butt of every joke
and I wish that we could go through the
our favorite not a single one of them
yeah it's safe for work there's a Kevin
McHale reference last night that was a
lovely woman yeah there I think the only
ones that we can say on air is like the
cloud botherer
yeah yeah the cloud botherers one that I
always liked and then his attempt to
derail the nicknames as tall McCartney
like his college buddies call him tall
McCartney before I let you go to have a
good Julia louis-dreyfus story that you
could just throw out there just working
with her getting know her or anything
she's a genius she's managed I mean like
it's a heart it would be hard I would be
hard-pressed to pull one specific one
out mmm but only because she she's so
incredible as a cast mate and as a
collaborator and as somebody who was at
the front of this show and worked
tirelessly for its success mm-hmm I
can't say enough about her and she's a
great person she's great to work with it
was Mother's Day yesterday she's a great
mom your kids are awesome I cannot say
enough about her but there is like when
we were on Colbert as a cast and I made
a joke that was with like sort of in the
moment made a joke this in the past week
right yeah this past Thursday I think we
were all the whole cast was on Colbert
and there's this there's this thing that
happens every once in a while you'll
throw something out and you get this
very specific look from Julia of like of
like proud or like that was a good one
and it kind of involves like this little
there's almost like a little it's like
there's like this little thing like it's
almost like just kind of gently pointing
it out like I really like that and it
doesn't happen all the time like
sometimes she laughs but there's this
very specific thing of like ooh I really
liked that one and I got one of those
that night and it reminded me like oh
that always feels good when you can link
when something happens and you made the
funniest person that's ever been on
television laughs like that feels really
good like she shares she shares the joy
and she shares the the like the oh man
just like the the what do you call it
like um man I'm having a stroke no
you're not you're just all talk down on
this show she's so she's just so joyful
about everything and shares that
whatever yeah yeah I mean and and just
one last thing on it too because I don't
want to give away too much from last
night
yeah but it was there was kind of a
serious ending and it was also a moment
where she had a human moment amongst her
not being very nice that not many people
could play that and hit that note and be
funny as well funny
I know it's awesome she's really able
she's sort of uniquely talented and able
to do stuff like that where just can
bounce back and forth but I do love the
fact that man it ends and the way like
you get everything you wanted and at
what cost you know you're the man
Timothy I love having you on here come
back anytime you want with everything
that you're doing from here on awesome
in this on Instagram and Twitter right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app